just don't know if there's any part of
your brain that you can just remove and
it's fine though I think there is you
think like people get brain surgery all
the time to get pieces removed and
they're fine that's true
is that true yeah we just Google it real
quick I've been thinking about just
getting like a minor lobotomy yeah
just a low-key
low-key lobotomy yeah
lkl it's a BBL big brain lobotomy I'm
too smart no but you can how much of
your brain can you live without well
most of uh brain fellow no more than
five percent of the cranial cavity LED
normal lives
hmm people like TJ Miller yeah he had uh
he I don't know I forget what he had but
he had like a stroke or something like
that and had a piece of his brain
removed and oh totally functional okay I
mean sometimes your personality changes
but yeah dude I'm totally the same I
just can't remember anything yeah but on
the same guy yeah who are you again